et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
brigitte klinkert bonjour bonjour coûts
et d'être avec nous le délégué chargé de
l'insertion
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale et on
retrouve ce matin avec plaisir stéphane
vernet bonjour stéphane bonjour qui
dirigea la rédaction parisienne du
journal ouest france
brigitte klinkert le gouvernement qui en
cette rentrée s'attaque là
principalement à deux sujets la sécurité
la lutte contre le séparatisme
strasbourg et mulhouse dans votre
département votre région sont touchés
par ces phénomènes vous avez été vous
présidente du département il ya encore
peu est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas que
le gouvernement arrive trop tard sur ces
sujets je pense vraiment qu'aujourd'hui
c'est une priorité pour le gouvernement
d'ailleurs demain lors du séminaire
gouvernemental
eh bien ça sera l'un des deux sujets qui
sera à l'ordre du jour vous savez la
sécurité c'est d'une part la pré la
prévention et en tant que ministre de
l'insertion et bien je suis dans la
prévention mercier et s'est d'autre part
la la répression on sort aussi j'espère
qu'on sort d'une crise sanitaire qui a
été très très dur avec va en parler mais
c'est vraiment sur ces sujets de
séparatisme de sécurité vous qui avait
été élu local est ce que encore une
seule et l'état n'arrive pas trop tard
est ce que les élus locaux n'ont pas
déjà fait une grande partie du travail
alors c'est un vrai sujet mais sur ce
sujet là comme sur les autres mon avis
est qu'il faut jouer collectif que
l'état tout seul ne peut rien et
justement en tant que ministre et en
tant qu'élu local puisque je suis vice
présidente du conseil départemental du
rhin j'estime que quel que soit le sujet
quelle que soit la politique menée ce
n'est qu'ensemble état et collectivités
avec les acteurs locaux qu'on peut
avancer
vous venez d'évoquer le séminaire
gouvernemental en disant c'est une des
deux questions d'autres questions ces
plans de relance évidemment est-ce que
vous aurez des des choses particulières
à mettre sur la table au cours de ce
séminaire alors le plan de relance et
et juste un plan de relance exceptionnel
vous le savez quatre fois plus que le
plan de relance de 2008 avec 100
milliards d'euros c'est juste énorme
la priorité des priorités du
gouvernement
ce sont les jeunes parce que 750 mille
jeunes se retrouvent chaque année sur le
marché du travail
ça c'est votre domaine alors l'insertion
des jeunes mais l'insertion de est bien
de l'ensemble des publics fragiles c'est
c'est ça mon domaine monde leit motiv
mon objectif c'est de ne laisser
personne personne sur le bord de la
route et on le sait lorsqu il y à une
crise économique
tout le monde souffre les entreprises
souffrent mais ceux qui souffrent le
plus ce sont ceux qui sont éloignés de
l'emploi
et parce qu'ils vont avoir encore plus
de difficultés en trouver et mon
objectif est bien c'est d'être à leurs
côtés pour leur permettre de s'insérer
de trouver un emploi parce que trouver
un emploi c'est changer la vie de la
personne qui tient cet emploi et
s'échanger aussi la vie de toute une
famille dans le plan de relance il est
question de trois milliards d'euros
estime le trou pas vivre de 3 milliards
d'euros pour l'insertion des jeunes
est-ce que c'est suffisant au regard des
enjeux je les dis
la priorité des priorités c'est le plan
de relance pour les jeunes et le plan de
relance pour les jeunes c'est 6,5
milliards d'euros leur enveloppe globale
l'enveloppé globale c'est juste énorme
c'est juste un plan massif et nous
voulons trouver une solution adaptée à
chaque jeune alors il y à de nombreux
dispositifs qui qui ont été mis en place
et peut-être un peu détaillé ça c'est
une solution pour chaque jeune c'est ce
qu'avait annoncé le président de la
république fin juillet dans son discours
ça se déclinent comment il ya d'abord la
prime de 4000 euros
al embauche pour les moins de 26 ans
plus de trois mois enfin cdd ou cdi et
l'autre le le reste c'est vrai qu'il ya
1 200 me de formation spéciale il y a
beaucoup de mesures il ya des formations
également qui sont proposées aux jeunes
pour les métiers de l'avenir dans le
domaine du numérique dans le dos mais ce
que ça c'est près de la décharge
radiologie pour cette rentrée alors nous
sommes en train de travailler en
particulier avec l'afpa qui va lancer
qui en train de lancer des formations
dans les territoires mais c'est aussi
des formations qualifiantes
ce sont des formations aussi dans
l'enseignement supérieur
le plan jeunes ce sont aussi 300 milles
parcours d'insertion et d'accompagnement
en plus de 200000 formation en plus des
200 milles formation pour les jeunes les
plus éloignés de l'emploi et se sont
tout un tas d'autres mesures notamment
une mesure qui me tient à coeur aussi ce
sont les services civiques
parce que les services civiques
permettent à des jeunes qui sont un
petit peu loin de tout aussi et bien de
remettre en pied dans la société et de
reprendre espoir
ce que je voulais ce qui me semble
important aussi puisqu'on on parle de
milliards en l'occurrence de 6,5
milliards d'euros pour le plan jeunes ce
sont surtout des solutions concrètes que
nous voulons apporter à ces jeunes pour
qu'ils puissent avoir un espace est ce
que je peux juste reprendre le chiffre
que vous souhaitiez vous disiez 750
mille jeunes arrivent sur le marché du
travail
là quand je vous écoute il ya deux cent
mille places de formation pour prolonger
les études 300000 que vous venez de
citer parcours d'insertion d'insertion
l'usiné service civique est ce que ça
veut dire que vous vous attendez à ce
que quasiment aucun jeune ou presque ne
parviennent à trouver du travail en
cette rentrée particulièrement difficile
du fait de la crise sanitaire tout tout
est mi temps tout est mis en oeuvre
aujourd'hui pour que justement chaque
jeune trouve une solution
nous avons beaucoup demandé beaucoup de
sacrifices aux jeunes durant la crise
sanitaire
c'est vrai que je ne veux pas entendre
moi parler d'une génération sacrifiée
ça n'est juste pas entendable pour la
ministre déléguée à l'insertion et donc
mon objectif même s'il est ambitieux
c'est vraiment de trouver une solution
pour chaque cours chacun juste stéphane
le rappeler un seul chiffre de 1,3
milliard dans le plan de relance
consacré à à l'insertion des jeunes
précisément tout ça dans les laurentides
5 milliards si je fume père lui dans le
plan dans le plan jeunes présentés mais
dont 1,3 milliard parmi les 100
milliards a annoncé il ya quelques jours
par jean castex comment comment
précisément ils vont être utilisé ses
1,3 milliard lalande relance alors
précisément tout à l'heure lorsqu'en
parlait de sécurité je disais l'état ne
peut rien faire tout seul et bien là
aussi nous allons nous appuyer
évidemment sur les acteurs locaux
en premier lieu les missions locales qui
vont repérer les jeunes et puis ensuite
eh bien je parlais de la faim qui va
proposer des formations des formations
qualifiantes qui vont être proposés
également de l'enseignement supérieur
qui va proposer de la formation métiers
d'avenir mais surtout surtout aussi
l'insertion
certes ce sont des formations avec
l'obligation de formation maintenant de
16 ans à 18 ans qui pour moi est très
importante pour dans le cadre de
l'égalité des chances
parce que vous savez bien l'égalité des
chances c'est maintenant l'obligation de
la scolarité à partir de 3 ans et bien
ce qui est important pour nous
aujourd'hui c'est que de 16 ans à 18 ans
les jeunes poursuivent une formation une
formation ça veut pas dire forcément
l'école lorsqu on le sait beaucoup de
ces jeunes qui sont éloignés
est qui et qui cherche à éviter l'école
il faut surtout pas leur en parler mais
à d'autres formations que l'école
j'étais notamment l'apprentissage
notamment cherche à relancer notamment
l'apprentissage je vais beaucoup aussi
dans les départements dans les
territoires et il ya beaucoup
d'initiatives très très passionnante qui
se font par exemple dans le domaine du
sport d'essayer de ramener vers l'emploi
et tout simplement de remettre un pied
vraiment dans la société les jeunes à
travers le sport parce que vous savez on
parle beaucoup de diplômes et bien sûr
je crois en l'école et je crois au cv on
a besoin de cv lorsqu'on se présente un
emploi mais j'étais jusqu'à il ya un
mois présidente de conseil départemental
lorsque je recrutais lorsque jean
bauchet serge gardelle cv mais
j'essayais de donner la chance à des
jeunes qui étaient très éloignées de
l'emploi qui habitaient dans des
quartiers difficiles
j'essayais même de leur donner la
priorité est pour moi plus que les
diplômes
c'était le savoir être et la volonté de
ces jeunes qui m'apportait et s'il ya
une ligne que je regardais vraiment sur
le cv c'était le sport quelles activités
sportives et ce qu'il fait parce qu'à
travers l'activité sportive à travers la
culture aussi mais à travers l'activité
sportive
eh bien on peut repérer les qualités et
les talents d'un jeune est justement
l'égalité des chances un enfant vous
venez de citer l'égalité des chances
c'est un déplacement du président la
république ce matin même à clermont
ferrand est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
un petit peu ce qui est de quel est
l'objet ou l'objectif de ce déplacement
et qu'est-ce qui va annoncer
alors il y aura des annonces et c'est
bien sûr au président de la république
d'annoncer tout à l'heure
un certain nombre encore la grande ligne
quand même pour moi vraiment là vous
savez il ya la loi la loi de pour
l'école de la confiance qui a été votée
l'an dernier
l'égalité des chances c'est de trois ans
à 18 ans il faut donner à tous les
jeunes d'où qu'ils viennent quelle que
soit leur origine
les mômes possibilité de réussir dans la
vie il y à tous les jeunes tout part
dans tous les ans environ 80 mille
jeunes qui sont sans qualification
notre objectif c'est aucun jeune ni en
emploi ni en formation donc donner à
chaque jeune soit un emploi soit une
formation les repérer et puis ensuite
les accompagnent et pas seulement vers
l'emploi mais dans l'emploi est ce qu'il
y aura des annonces par exemple sur le
l'apprentissage on sait que l'année
dernière a été une année record en
termes d'apprentissage t + 20 % à
produire de jeunes qui rentraient en
apprentis par rapport aux années
précédentes donc les efforts du
gouvernement précédent ont été payants
en la matière il ya une angoisse ou une
question qui se pose c'est avec le co
vide est ce qu'on va arriver aux mêmes
niveaux de taux d'entrée en
apprentissage est ce qu'on on peut
encore cette année faire aussi bien que
l'année dernière en la matière ou alors
il l'a aussi va y avoir un creux c'est
vrai que c'est une vraie question
du fait de la crise sanitaire suivi de
la crise économique que nous que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et je sens aussi
un certain nombre de chefs d'entreprise
aujourd'hui un petit peu frileux et on
les comprend
avant d'embaucher il se pose beaucoup de
questions parce que c'est une
responsabilité que l'embauché notamment
que du goyen j'aime bien c'est quoi le
coup de pouce pour les convaincre manama
le coup de pouce c'est justement l'aide
à l'embauché d'apprentis qui a été fait
par par le gouvernement et c'est de leur
dire aux chefs d'entreprise d'avoir
confiance d'avoir confiance en l'avenir
économique de notre pays à travers le
plan de relance massif de 100 milliards
d'euros que nous venons de mettre en
place
100 milliards d'euros c'est juste énorme
dans aucun pays européens voisins vous
ne retrouvez un plan de relance telles
que celui qui a été lancé par le
gouvernement français
et quand est ce que vous saurez vous
aurez l'assurance que cette confiance
est restaurée parce que 100 milliards
d'euros effectivement ces massifs en
même temps c'est bien que dans la
confiance des ressorts qui joue c'est
pas forcément une histoire de chiffres
c'est une version une histoire de
conviction et persuasion à quel moment
vous aurez à atteindre votre objectif
l'objectif du plan de relance c'est 100
milliards d'euros
c'est pour l'emploi et c'est pour les
territoires
ça veut dire que là aussi il faut
travailler au plus proche à les
convaincre à les expliquer vous savez
j'ai lancé la beaucoup news qui font
beaucoup de terrain depuis l'annoncé du
plan de relance ils sont partout en
france comme nous ça me donne des
interviews nous nous sommes partout et
c'est très important et c'est très
important
il y a quinze jours j'ai lancé avec
elisabeth bornes avec sophie cluzel un
plan de 300 millions d'euros pour
l'insertion
là aussi c'est du jamais vu et ce plan
est destiné d'une part à soutenir les
entreprises dans le domaine de
l'insertion mais aussi les entreprises
adaptées donc pour les personnes en
situation de handicap à les aider à
surmonter la crise parce qu'elles ont
évidemment beaucoup souffert et c'est
aussi un plan que nous avons mis en
place pour aider ces structures de
l'inclusion sociale comme on dit à se
transformer et à se développer parce que
quand l'économie a des difficultés que
les entreprises ont des difficultés et
bien les entreprises de l'insertion ou
encore de plus grandes difficultés il y
avait un certain nombre de projets
intéressants qui était qu'ils ont été
utiles et y mis à mal par le cos vide ou
pas je pense par exemple aux territoires
zéro chômeur pour l'instant il y en a
dix qui sont toujours en expérimentation
qu'est ce que vous allez en faire
finalement vous arrêter vous étendez
vous généralisez alors justement à
partir de la semaine prochaine le texte
la proposition de loi territoire zéro
chômeur va être examiné c'est d'ailleurs
le premier texte qui va être examiné par
l'assemblée nationale
à partir du l'ouverture de la session
c'est un signe et que s'est posée c'est
un signe pour le gouvernement et c'est
un signe de l'assemblée nationale de
montrer l'importance qu'elle attache à
l'insertion et à l'insertion par
l'activité économique ce qui est proposé
avec la députée madame verdier jouclas
quelle hauteur et la rapporteure du
texte c'est l'insertion de personnes qui
sont très très éloignées de l'emploi
donc territoire zéro chômeur existe déjà
il ya une expérimentation de le battre
voilà c'est une expérimentation n'aura
plus ce qui est appelé à être développé
voilà ça sera l'un des objets de la
discussion justement la semaine
prochaine à l'assemblée nationale
territoire zéro chômeur s'est donnée
proposer un cdi à des personnes qui sont
très éloignées de l'emploi
et c'est donc leur donner une chance et
bien de retrouver une place dans la
société et de leur redonner l'espoir
dans la vie derrière un accord une
généralisation
alors vous savez il ya une
expérimentation qui a été lancée sur sur
une dizaine de territoires
nous attendons d'ailleurs encore les
retours nous n'avons pas tous les rendus
plusieurs rapports pour sonia de
plusieurs genres il ya plusieurs
rapports moi il me semble très important
de poursuivre cette expérimentation
peut-être un jour de la généraliser mais
ça ne peut pas ne pas encore à l'ordre
du jour pour pour développer le secteur
de l'insertion et permettent parce que
c'est vraiment là l'objectif aux
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
de trouver d'obtenir un cdi dans des
entreprises qui sont dans les
territoires au plus proche des
préoccupations des habitants est au plus
proche aussi des nécessités qui se font
jour sur le territoire j'avais vu juste
une dernière question celle ci en visant
deux servent à l'analyse de l'insertion
également donc il y avait un certain
nombre de territoires qui ont été qui
ont été choisis que 14 de mémoire zh
l'expérimentation devait commencer au
mois de mars en plein confinement du
coup
est ce qu'elle a pu avoir lieu est ce
que tout a été mis cul par dessus tête
ce sera à vous reporter qu'est ce qui se
passe du coup avec eux avec les séries
alors effectivement le service public de
l'insertion dans l'emploi et j'y tiens
dans l'emploi et a été expérimentée à
partir d'une expérimentation même alors
pour dire la vérité l'expérimentation
démarre maintenant parce que pendant la
crise du coc vite ça a été très très
compliqué de le faire mais c'est pour
moi une priorité
le service public de l'insertion de
l'emploi pourquoi parce que dans le
domaine de l'insertion il ya des acteurs
multiples sur le terrain il ya des
dispositifs qui sont multiples ci est
donc un problème de lisibilité et de
visibilité
l'objectif c'est tout simple et léger
avoir un interview de l'organique pour
la voir dans le pré stage à voir j'ai
envie de dire enfin parce que ça fait 10
ans ou quinze ans qu'on parle d'
interlocuteur unique donc d'avoir un
référent unique qui accompagne tout au
long de ce parcours le bénéficiaire
et quand on parle d' accompagnement
c'est l'accompagnement social et c'est
aussi l'accompagnement vers et dans
l'emploi ale vrai j'étais un carton va
aller dans votre département on va
retrouver laurent bodin qui est
journaliste à l'alsace et votre journal
local laurent rebonjour vous avez des
questions pour brigitte klinkert sur la
collectivité européenne d'alsace sourire
bonjour yann bonjour madame klinkert
madame coeur de l'actualité politique en
alsace outre les élections sénatoriales
c'est la disparition le 1er janvier
prochain des conseils départementaux du
haut-rhin et du bas-rhin qui vont
fusionner donc dans une entité appelée
collectivités européennes d'alsace est
ce qu'il n'ya pas un risque d'éloigner
un peu plus les élus les centres de
décisions des citoyens alors le 1er
janvier prochain c'est surtout la
naissance de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace qui a une naissance attendue et
tous les alsaciens vous le savez
monsieur gaudin sans s'en réjouissent
parce que c'est une co-construction qui
a été réalisé entre les élus alsaciens
et le gouvernement et qui va faire de
l'alsace une collectivité n'ont pas un
statut particulier mais qui aura une
place tout à fait unique dans dans le
territoire institutionnels français et
qu'après
harry après lyon après la corse est bien
l'alsace sera une collectivité qui aura
des compétences des deux départements
mais qui aura des compétences nouvelles
qui lui viendront à la fois de l'état et
j'entends par là le développement du
bilinguisme la coopération
transfrontalière le transfert des routes
et des autoroutes avec un mécanisme de
régulation du transit poids lourd
puisque le transit des poids lourds en
alsace c'est juste une catastrophe
et puis des compétences qui nous
viennent de la région notamment dans le
domaine de l'attractivité du tourisme et
l'engagement que nous avons pris
frédéric berry moi même et l'ensemble
des conseillers départementaux alsacien
est bien c'est que cette collectivité
soit encore plus proche que ne le sont
aujourd'hui les départements
d'ailleurs lorsque j'étais présidente du
conseil départemental
j'ai remis en place des animateurs dans
les territoires au plus proche des élus
locaux au plus proche des habitants pour
que cette collectivité
demain ne soit pas une collectivité qui
soient centralisés ni à colmar ni à
strasbourg ni à mulhouse mais qu'ils
soient partout dans les territoires et
justement laurent en question sur le
choix du ch 1 de cette collectivité et
le choix du siège et la question de la
présidence est ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de revivre la guerre entre eux ou
la guéguerre entre les bas rhinois et
les haut rhinois entre mulhouse colmar
et strasbourg
quel est votre choix pour le siège de
cette collectivité européenne d'alsace
est ce que votre nomination au
gouvernement elle ne l'était pas la voie
libre au président du conseil
départemental du bas-rhin frédéric guéry
qui ne semble pas près d'accepter une
présidence tournante de 7 c à vous vous
savez nous avons construit ensemble élus
alsaciens avec le gouvernement cette
collectivité européenne d'alsace plus
que jamais je me sens garante de la
réussite de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace je me suis d'ailleurs exprimé
en juillet à ce sujet
le siège pour moi ne doit pas être un
sujet c'est le premier ministre du
gouvernement précédent edouard philippe
l'avait dit ce sont aux élus alsaciens
le moment venu de décider du siège
donc c'est à la nouvelle assemblée de
décider avec frédéric berry d'ailleurs
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord pour
dire que certes sur le papier il faudra
un siège mais cette nouvelle assemblée
pourra aussi bien ceux se retrouver à
colmar cah strasbourg qu'à mulhouse mais
aussi à saint louis à haguenau et
saverne et c'est à ce que ce que ne nous
voulons surtout pas faire monsieur
gaudin c'est centralisé à l'échelle de
l'alsace ce que nous voulons au
contraire c'est avoir une collectivité
européenne d'alsace au plus proche des
habitants pour moi aussi il n'y a pas de
de guerre des chefs nous avons réussi ce
projet collectivement et bien nous
continuerons à le mettre en route
collectivement et je suis sûr que ce
sera une grande réussite au bénéfice des
alsaciennes et des alsaciens et des
mères si on a encore deux questions à
vous poser brigitte klinkert merci
beaucoup merci laurent godin d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin de questions
d'actualité qui concernent encore votre
région c'est la crise sanitaire ont fait
le grand test a été particulièrement
touché par la première vague est ce que
les leçons ont été tirées pour vous
est-ce qu'il est pertinent de réduire la
14ème comme l'envisagé le gouvernement
alors effectivement le notre région
était très très touché le département du
haut rhin
très très très fort j'ai passé deux mois
non plus à m'occuper de la construction
de la collectivité européenne d'alsace
ou des grands dossiers mais j'ai passé
deux mois on peut le dire a essayé de
sauver des vies c'était juste juste une
catastrophe
aujourd'hui ce que j'ai envie de dire à
tous les français c'est porter le masque
les gestes barrières sont fondamentaux
il faut vraiment que les français soient
responsabilisées se sentent responsables
des autres parce que je ne souhaite pas
que l'on puisse revivre une deuxième
vague et c'est pourquoi aussi pour moi
il est important et bien que les préfets
puissent prendre des arrêtés pour que le
port du masque soir dumas obligatoire
dans un certain nombre de villes
notamment à strasbourg où
malheureusement les indicateurs
aujourd'hui ne sont pas très fin et
réduire la 14è nas que c'est pas un
mauvais signal dans ce contexte vous
savez j'ai eu beaucoup de contacts avec
des experts les experts nous disent il
faut aborder de ce virus avec une grande
humilité parce qu'on en sait peu de
choses
et tous les jours on apprend autre chose
sur ce virus mais qui le lendemain
éventuellement est remis en question
donc moi je fais confiance aux experts à
les dernières questions politiques
stéphane aller sans transition très vite
le en 2019 vous étiez encore aux
républicains vous avez vous avez quitté
partie est ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui
vous avez rejoint la république en
marche ou es ce que vous avez
l'intention de le faire alors j'ai
toujours été une élue locale engagée
dans ce que j'appellerais la majorité
alsacienne
aujourd'hui je suis membre du
gouvernement dans la majorité
gouvernementale dents dans la majorité
dans la majorité présidentielle mais
vous n'avez pas pris votre adhésion en
jeune et je n'ai pas d'étiquette
politique
pour moi ce qui importe c'est l'avenir
du pays c'est de servir mon pays et
merci beaucoup merci moi j'ai une carte
d'avoir été à notre invité ce matin
merci stéphane demain à votre place ce
sera gérard larcher le président du
sénat pour une émission spéciale être
avec nous pendant une heure pour
répondre aux questions des journalistes
de la presse quotidienne régionale et
ont pas de sous titres au club des
territoires